you guys were so good in this movie you
need to know i'm a huge she's all that
fan so i went into this i was like okay
let's give it a chance and i loved it so
i think fans will love it from the
original
new fans did you guys have that
chemistry was that instant or is that
something that kind of built at the
movie went on
i feel like it was pretty instant i
think instant yeah we got to know each
other super quick we uh dove right in
and we got to know each other and the
crazy things and the deep things and um
and yeah i mean we had a blast together
and we really spent we spent a good
amount of time together before we really
started filming and um and yeah i think
it was just it was just natural it was
easy yeah yeah you know you guys are
awesome together addison with this being
your first feature film you know you're
this tick tock star and now you're the
lead of this film what was that whole
experience like did you get any advice
um from rachel cook yeah i mean she's
was incredible to work with she still
you know gives me advice now and then i
got to hear from her today and we got to
really just catch up and talk again and
um she's been so kind just about you
know really going for it and don't let
anyone tell you what you can and can't
do and um i mean you know
being able to be in this film is truly a
dream come true and something that's so
indescribable even watching the film and
seeing the trailer come out and the
response was so amazing to see people
just really believe in me and support me
and um and that was just so incredible
to be able to do with such an amazing
cast and crew
i love that ken were you familiar with
the original film i was extremely
familiar with the original film um i'm
my guilty pleasure is definitely
romantic movies and rom-coms that's a
lot of what i like to watch in general
so
nothing's wrong with that i had seen it
multiple multiple times and then
actually continued to watch it a few
times before we started shooting just so
i had
you know the essence of it even though
it's a remake you know and reimagining i
wanted to make sure that you know we
still had kind of that original there uh
and everything that i was trying to
portray so oh no you definitely did
addison i know you and your mom are a
fan of the original
um did she freak out when you got the
role in this film
yeah we both did i remember we were in
the car whenever i got the phone call
you know saying i got the roll and i was
crying hysterically and she was also
just freaking out couldn't really
breathe i feel like it was such a big
you know a big moment and we were both
like
in shock still but like crying but like
excited and she loved the movie like you
said and um yeah it was really amazing
and just being able to you know be a
part of something so iconic and and
really put our take on it was just
undescribable absolutely now with this
being your first feature film i know
this is kourtney kardashian's first
feature film i know your friends was
that nice getting to share that moment
together so nice it was so amazing i
mean i became friends with so much of
the cast and being able to bring someone
on that you know i had been friends with
outside of the film was just so so fun
and someone like her who is so open to
doing anything and and so real and so
down and it was it was really exciting
she enjoyed it we were both nervous but
had so much fun together and got to
experience that together i was gonna ask
are you guys nervous yeah definitely
nervous i mean i think you know no
matter how much preparation you put into
really anything when you get in front of
those cameras or or get into that that
moment it's like okay here we go you
know this is the time let's make it
happen and uh and yeah she was she was
nervous when she came on set and she was
like i don't know what it's gonna what's
what do you do how do you wanna work it
and i was just like we got this you know
act like you're having a normal
conversation with me and you're gonna
kill it well you guys were fantastic in
this congratulations on the film so nice
getting to talk to both of you thank you
thank you so much